Shawn do you write everyday do I write
everyday I do now
I don't always I'm working on a
screenplay that I'm trying to finalize
so yeah I write every every day but I'll
definitely go through phases where I
can't write you know or where I can't
write or I don't feel like I have the
ability to write you know and when you
go through that or did you used to be
hard on yourself and now you just accept
it as part of the process or how does
that work no I don't accept
I'm always hard on myself and I don't
accept that as part of the process I
just I I just am sort of always
rewriting as I write and never happy
with anything out of the gate I guess
what I'll say to you is that I don't
write very quickly in that respect I
sort of inch by inch word by word go
through the the pages and I think I'm a
little bit of a slower writer in that
respect and other people because if I
give them a first draft to somebody the
chances are it's it's more like a fifth
or sixth draft you know I've kind of
like I'll go the next day and just
rewrite what I did the day before then
get into new stuff you know okay
so you'll go back and sort of revise you
won't put it in a drawer for three weeks
and no I never I don't I don't know if I
ever blast through pages you know which
is from rare for me like if I were just
like without five pages you can be sure
that the next day I will rewrite those
pages and then I'll rewrite them again
the next Friday and then I'll rewrite it
I'll probably write them about eleven
times before they ever see the light of
day to a person reading them you know I
mean it's not gonna say it takes seven
years or anything but I I'm always sort
of just kind of getting caught up in the
polishing and the making sure of this
the aesthetic of the script is as
important as the
the characters and the story and
narrative you know making sure the pages
read like butter is very important to to
me and to the reader to whether that be
a producer or an actor or actress or a
financier it's it's part of it and I
have some reason I go down those rabbit
holes a lot do you think that comes from
being a musician as well or just oh I
don't know I don't know where it comes
from I think it comes from I don't know
I just I I just if a word is off or
wrong or if something doesn't feel like
you know it if there's a rhythm off of
the dialogue I think this actually more
comes from improv classes you know
because when I was in college I really
just wanted to be an actor and in when
you do improv and I was in a few
different groups and a few different
acting coaches one of them actually
passed away a few months ago but when
you improvise it's a very empowering
enlightening thing and I think it it's
great if you are a writer to have that
experience because essentially what you
can do then is you can take two
characters and really not know where
anything is going and let them improvise
on the page and that's how I write
really is I bound I improvise between
two characters on me well what would I
like the next person to say what would
be nice and and what's the good rhythm
and then I hate it the next day you know
that's basically how it works
you